all right before we go let's make this
week's visit to the red chair so who's
there who's there hello hi hi what's
your name
Michelle Michelle lovely and were you
from Mattel I'm from Peru
really yes wow that's a first lady
together but we have not had a peruvian
so well she's a Perez also ship early
they said really like she's lying
I know somebody must be from Peru but
then she took she's not gonna be sitting
on a llama it's just right to do that
advice sorry my dear would you be
distracted now dude but you live here
now
yes I live in London all right what do
you do I'm a chef
oh right like a posh restaurant ER or
pop you know now I'm a private chef KIV
chef in somebody's house yes so with
someone watching this now going where's
my dinner
beans on toast break hey off you go
with the story um my parents came over
to visit um me and my fiance and my
dad's very environmentally friendly so
on their first night he decided to turn
off all the appliances we miss Paroo
magic was amazing about this and I think
I might have got an insight into what
you're like as a director there
she went so and Shawn just turned around
and went in his eyes he just went she's
not gonna survive a beautiful movie
let's try another one let's try another
one hello hello
no no no no I think you're really
enjoying it cream what is the record for
the most number of people that have done
whatever will run out this lot can all
get in say 600 people who wants to be
drugged by short they're okay let's go
another one now
hi what's your name I'm Maggie Maggie
good luck Maggie where do you live
Maggie I'm South African but I live in
Ascot
you know Ascot she lives in an escort
don't know she lives in a car
no is it a scar oh yes with races are
yes yes okay brilliant
yeah so off you go with your short um a
few years ago um my husband and I took
the family to Francine on Monday and for
a holiday yeah and and we're indeed
going and we were on the water side and
we kept going up and down the slides
with the kids going having fun and then
my husband decided to go and keep going
ice creams for us and then um I was
wearing a nice gold a swimsuit and I
thought I look
I'm an extra can you do me a favor on
the next one when you can you do like a
kick like you did to that blocks like
you're kicking them out of the air will
give you a shovel to hit the safe okay
hello sir hello hi what's your name Jake
Jake lovely Jake and that what do you do
I'm a student of drama and applied
theater and education now I die I was
always doing the Emory technique
off you go with this story well my story
starts in Zimbabwe where I volunteered
for three months in my gut yeah last
year yeah and that's why my god here
yeah God what is that it's a thing that
rich kids take the way to pronounce it
it's like you would say don't we have
that get a job here
go to college here yeah live on a
mattress and don't go to college the way
you said it you know it's like got yeah
but he's a gab yah yeah even be funny he
would be fun man buddy anyway you're in
Zimbabwe you volunteered
yeah to do something yes hell presumably
children yeah yeah Praeger teaching in a
school very good
Marley irrelevant but um yeah I had an
argument with my housemates and I
decided to cool off by should go for a
run so I decided you know what I should
probably go for a run and we didn't need
you for that one
that was a very poor storytelling right
there okay can we put him back in and
watch your dick it will have one more
it's a problem so glad you don't have
these for us hello hi hi you you join us
up quite a tough evening
I will not let you go out with him if I
don't get this moment so right you know
she what she said oh my god big thing is
I'll just draw a mustache on her
I just got little French curly mustache
and then I just let energy goes off and
she forgets about it I forget about it